house coma resumes Fiona Pat welcome
back to vanish we played this forever
ago didn't we
it felt like a long time ago and I saw
it the game got updated so I figured hey
let's check it out
let's see what's what in the butt oh god
I forgot how [ __ ] terrifying this
can't fit all right we're being dragged
across some wet hello what's going on
here am i walking the hell is this
okay oh what the [ __ ]
Oh minecraft who flipped out can you
throw me in here come on rude you know I
hate limes
all right god I'm surrounded bad in
actually I love lambs blood twist all
right I remember this you walk through
here and it's it's cozy and nice hello
they shift to run whoa that is trippy
[ __ ] man that is trapeze shot if you
know what I'm trying
oh god don't do that don't do that
we're fine we're gonna do this [ __ ]
price I got this accessories gotcha
that's great oh yeah the notes how do I
read them Hank I'm sure what's going on
I'm not sure what's going on all I'm
getting is static on the radio Val and
you said we never need those new bets ha
phil was one [ __ ] that would snitch
about the notepads well it's pretty cozy
so far I feel very tall that makes me
feel good about myself not like a little
girl or some [ __ ] I get scared
Oh God [ __ ] this cuz I just cuz I say Oh
God doesn't mean I'm scared
it just means I I think about Jesus
dammit Hank did you piss down here
Suffolk's mix can be a game why we
didn't bring the extra flashlight with
us this shitty glow sticks left no Phil
well I don't even have a glow sticks so
you know I'd appreciate it if you give
me one cos you know I like to party I'm
a rave party that's what I do on my free
time I don't know what you breasts do
some kind of sick [ __ ] oh jesus [ __ ]
bikes why would you do that
that's good oh whoa whoa whoa what the
[ __ ] is that
Hank Phil oh god I'm Hank Phil Phil
Dunphy Jake says
oh my god why would he do that why would
he do that
that must be the spawn of just oh my god
chill out man
relaxing all cool and all should sell
[ __ ] I'm not even gonna do you not gonna
that's what we do in Sweden that's oh
and then we do a lot better this a lot
of bad nuts smells really weird what did
I do with that finger
nothing
alright let's focus whoa I don't have a
real job that I was at Luna yeah I don't
have that - give me the Goss six alright
you should be nine octopus
alright it feels like I'm walking in
circles that other walls are moving on
me where the hell is the water Perihan
again Phil fell you son of a bat no but
that oh god oh god
alright Oh God all right all right all
right let's just pretend that he all
right he's there it's real isn't it Dell
fairly say yeah all right you know I
don't know what you did but I'm just
gonna walk over here and pretend yeah
ah Phil Phil Dunphy what are you doing
right Jesus Jade says stop it you don't
know how to say hi
what stop it see if we can pass him out
nope we're dead
we did all right we [ __ ] up it's all
right it's all right it's cool it's cool
don't worry we're still alive take it
bro that's beautiful
you have a beautiful extract me again
I'll I'll [ __ ] all over there and spank
you
I think I don't want to do it you're 12
well that's inappropriate I'm sorry I
won't do it you know why they call it
vanish because your balls will vanish
into thin air Oh God that must be Phil
Phil's hat man I miss fell he was such a
cool guy damn it I didn't let him but I
forgot a kiddie game I'm the last glass
dick anyway I'd be able to face them
with it yesterday
thank [ __ ] it's Hank now with all this
character it's been I don't even know
all right
I don't know which way to go all lit the
lid off king kelana COFF COFF alone i
pinky born all lit the lid off I don't
like that attempt at that beef puff puff
due for anything rub all right this way
I don't need glow sticks I can just come
on come on I don't need glow sticks I
can just party with my notes baby
another note from Hank okay bill if you
see this my radio is past it getting
back to the axe ladder to grab a product
Iseman Hank [ __ ] sake Hank what did
you do down here and why am i down here
why does no one love me when the arrows
point that way now what the fudge
doesn't make any sense
what how did that even makes a what
oh let's party let's party baby how do I
glow stick there we go this is how you
glow stick move and with their glow
stick Oh everybody
what are you doing minecraft what the
[ __ ] seriously
alright let's try that again shall we
well I found this place and I'm not even
chased by anyone
it's amazing amazing get it cuz it may
surprise high five
chill take a chill pill
gosh can a man have a glow stick without
having to feel like [ __ ] is about to
explode him and stuff no alright let's
follow this hair okay man look not near
NATO for a yearly birthday held a bit
distorted you have no filter it's
reminds me of the catacombs in Paris man
Oh for [ __ ] sake let me go oh there we
go you'll never have my hole that was
gay but that is okay I am NOT prejudiced
despite common belief on time there oh
hello
I'll go in you then I'm swimming around
and a pagina sorry for the singing I'll
see you on the other server all right we
made it this is very great I don't know
where I'm doing like off a foxy
you're not gonna alright he's gonna ah
Jesus
Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
Jason no Jason Jason Jason Jason
what the [ __ ] Jason
is he still there or did he disappear
into thin air
I'm a rapper girl I'm a rapper sorry I'm
not a rapper with what are you got you
to a budget [ __ ] job loudly held back
then don't do that shot oh god oh god
just go I'm Yara
I'm not your home that's it what the
[ __ ] my civic chase I don't like this
night laughs Jesus
with the fudge what is going on I don't
like this
hello I'm Swedish guard me oh god dang
it alright I get it
don't kill me please
okay wait please man my goose nips are
out of control right now I love it hmm I
wish I could show it no that would be
flag to [ __ ] I'm sorry bro sets on
another website for only 99.99 you can
get a monthly subscriptions it's called
beards nips calm I have a wide selection
of other youtubers nips as well in case
you're interesting I know it's a
shameful plug but you know gotta make
that money you gotta make that money
[ __ ]
oh hello this looks new alright Hank I'm
not sure what the [ __ ] and [ __ ] alright
that's great
you know what Hank I don't like you I
said it I said it before actually so I
don't even know why your your feelings
are hurt everyone's feelings are hurt
every once in a while just deal with it
right Hank
that's Hanks favorite hat it's called
mr. Hatter
I don't know why it's [ __ ] stupid
name but I guess Hank doesn't have a
great an imagination so such a loser
he wears because he's going bald which
is okay but I mean he wears a toupee and
I'm like Hank just deal with it
please I want to eat that toupee it
looks delicious if you're gonna tease me
with delicious hair then at least put it
on your chest like normal people
do you understand me Hank yeah not all
right you know what I'm gonna take that
as a yes all right all right I'm just
gonna take this note Hank what are you
are you getting many eggs job love it I
didn't even know we're here
I think there's something down here with
that I feel like every department room
to head for the keys no
failed with a brow Hank was a ho not
good what what all right I don't think
we're gonna get much further Bruce I
really like this game
it's very cool credits to these chaps go
ahead and never like enjoy watching let
me know if you wanted me to try it and
give it another go and I'll see you in
the next one stay awesome breasts real
fast